Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“经常性收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Phineas Gage, the case that changed psychology forever. What happened when a man
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导课程。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。菲尼亚斯·盖奇（Phineas Gage），这个永远改变了心理学的案例。当一个人
had a freak accident sending a railroad spike through his brain and lived to tell the tale? The story of this man, Phineas Gage, isn't just shocking. It changed the way we understand the human brain forever. Stick around and we'll go through all the gory facts together. Hi I'm Dr. Marianne a qualified clinical psychologist and today we are diving into one of the most fascinating and influential case studies in the history of psychology and neuroscience that is the case of Phineas Gage. Phineas' story isn't just a tale of survival. It's a case that forever altered our understanding of the brain, personality and human behaviour. In this episode, we'll explore what happened to him, how it impacted his life and what his experience taught us about the brain's
遭遇了一场离奇事故，一根铁路道钉穿过大脑却奇迹生还，会发生什么？菲尼亚斯·盖奇的故事不仅令人震惊，它还永远改变了我们对人类大脑的理解。请留下来，我们将一起探讨所有惊人的事实。你好，我是临床心理学家Marianne博士，今天我们将深入探讨心理学和神经科学史上最迷人、最具影响力的案例研究之一，即菲尼亚斯·盖奇案。菲尼亚斯的故事不仅仅是一个生存故事，它是一个永远改变了我们对大脑、个性和人类行为理解的案例。在这一集中，我们将探讨他身上发生了什么，这对他的生活产生了什么影响，以及他的经历教会了我们关于大脑的什么知识。
incredible complexity. Let's take a look. It was September the 13th, 1848, in the small town of Cavendish, Vermont. Phineas Gage was a 25-year-old railroad foreman, known for being hardworking, responsible, and a natural leader. His job involved clearing rocks to make way for railway lines, and on this fateful day, he was using a tamping iron to pack explosive powder into a hole. But something went wrong. Somehow the powder ignited prematurely sending the iron rod which was over three feet long and an inch thick hurtling through his left cheek behind his eye and out the top of his skull. Miraculously it's said that Phineas Gage didn't even lose consciousness during this accident. He was reportedly able to walk and talk even shortly
让我们来看看。那是1848年9月13日，在佛蒙特州卡文迪什的一个小镇上。菲尼亚斯·盖奇是一位25岁的铁路工头，以勤奋、负责和天生的领导力而闻名。他的工作是清理岩石以便铺设铁轨。在那个决定性的日子里，他正在用一根捣固铁棒将炸药填入孔中。但出了点问题。不知何故，炸药提前引爆，那根三英尺多长、一英寸粗的铁棒穿过他的左脸颊，从眼后穿出，并从头骨顶部飞出。奇迹般的是，据说菲尼亚斯·盖奇在这次事故中甚至没有失去知觉。据报道，他甚至在事故发生后不久就能走路和说话，
after the accident but already perhaps a sign that he was not quite himself and was a little confused was becoming apparent because to the doctor who treated him, he is reported to have said, here is business, enough for you. Yeah, like I said, doesn't make a lot of sense. Whilst of course his survival was extraordinary in itself, really it's what happened after the accident that's captured the attention of scientists and doctors for generations since. Life after the accident. So before the accident, Phineas was described as kind, level-headed and dependable. But after the injury, his personality seemed to have undergone a radical transformation. His friends and his colleagues observed that he had become impulsive, irritable and even prone to fits of anger. He seemed to struggle to maintain his
但已经显露出他有些不对劲且感到困惑的迹象，因为据报道，他对治疗他的医生说：“这儿有活儿，够你干的。”是的，正如我所说，这听起来没什么逻辑。虽然他的生还本身就很非凡，但真正让科学家和医生几代人以来一直关注的是事故之后发生的事情。事故后的生活。在事故发生前，菲尼亚斯被描述为和蔼、冷静且可靠。但在受伤后，他的性格似乎发生了彻底的转变。他的朋友和同事观察到他变得冲动、易怒，甚至容易发脾气。他似乎难以维持
relationships and holding down steady employment became tricky for him. One of his doctors, John Harlow, wrote that Gage was no longer Gage. The once reliable foreman had somehow become entirely different. This shows us just how profoundly the brain itself influences personality and behavior. Perhaps one of the most heartening things about this case is that it didn't end in tragedy because it also shows us about the brain's ability to heal, adapt and to find new ways to tackle problems. And even found work as a stagecoach driver in South America. Whilst there it's even said that he managed to gain some semblance of normality. His former mannerisms and social skills were more evident. This stage of his life suggests that even
人际关系，保持稳定的工作也变得很困难。他的医生之一John Harlow写道，盖奇不再是盖奇了。这位曾经可靠的工头不知何故变得完全不同了。这向我们展示了大脑本身对个性和行为的影响有多么深远。也许这个案例中最令人欣慰的事情之一是它并没有以悲剧告终，因为它也向我们展示了大脑治愈、适应和寻找新方法解决问题的能力。他甚至在南美洲找到了一份驿站马车夫的工作。在那里，据说他甚至设法恢复了一些常态。他以前的举止和社交技巧变得更加明显。他生命中的这个阶段表明，即使
in the 19th century, there were glimpses of what we know as neuroplasticity. That is the brain's incredible ability to adapt and recover. What we learned from this case. Phineas Gage's case was groundbreaking for understanding the brain's role in shaping personality and behavior. What we learned from this case. Phineas Gage's case was groundbreaking for understanding the brain's role in shaping personality and behaviour. Here are some of our key lessons. Number 1. The role of the frontal lobe. Phineas Gage's injury specifically damaged his frontal lobe, which is an area of the brain responsible for decision making, emotional regulation and social behaviour. His case provided some of the first evidence that different parts of the brain serve different functions.
在19世纪，也已经出现了我们现在所知的神经可塑性的迹象。也就是大脑适应和恢复的惊人能力。我们从这个案例中学到了什么。菲尼亚斯·盖奇的案例对于理解大脑在塑造个性和行为方面的作用具有开创性意义。我们从这个案例中学到了什么。菲尼亚斯·盖奇的案例对于理解大脑在塑造个性和行为方面的作用具有开创性意义。以下是我们的一些关键教训。第一，额叶的作用。菲尼亚斯·盖奇的损伤特别损害了他的额叶，这是大脑中负责决策、情绪调节和社会行为的区域。他的案例提供了首批证据，证明大脑的不同部分具有不同的功能。
2. Brain and personality connection Phineas' story challenged the belief that personality was fixed and unchanging. It showed us how brain injuries can alter someone's behaviour and character. A revelation that had profound implications for the fields of psychology and neurology. 3. The beginnings of neuroplasticity. Though the term itself didn't come about until much later, Phineas Gage's eventual ability to regain some of his former skills hinted at the brain's remarkable capacity to adapt and to heal relevance today phineas gage's incredible story continues to resonate not just as a historical
第二，大脑与个性的联系。菲尼亚斯的故事挑战了“个性是固定且不变的”这一信念。它向我们展示了脑损伤如何改变一个人的行为和性格。这一发现对心理学和神经学领域产生了深远的影响。第三，神经可塑性的开端。虽然这个术语直到很久以后才出现，但菲尼亚斯·盖奇最终恢复部分原有技能的能力，暗示了大脑具有非凡的适应和治愈能力。当今的意义。菲尼亚斯·盖奇的惊人故事不仅作为历史上的
curiosity but also as a foundation for modern neuroscience and psychology brain injuries today his case helps us understand the challenges faced by individuals with traumatic brain injuries, also known as TBI. It's paved the way for research into rehabilitation and recovery, which provides hope for people themselves who experience brain injuries, but also their friends and family around them, as there can be such a significant impact when it feels like you have lost the person that you love. Ethical considerations. Phineas Gage's story also helps us to raise questions and to look more closely at how we deal with people who form case studies.
好奇点，而且作为现代神经科学和心理学的基石，继续引起共鸣。当今的脑损伤。他的案例帮助我们理解了创伤性脑损伤（TBI）患者所面临的挑战。它为康复和恢复研究铺平了道路，这不仅为经历脑损伤的人们自己提供了希望，也为他们周围的朋友和家人带来了希望，因为当感觉失去了所爱之人时，这种影响是非常巨大的。伦理考量。菲尼亚斯·盖奇的故事也帮助我们提出问题，并更仔细地审视我们如何对待那些成为案例研究对象的人。
In the 19th century, it's of course fair to say that documentation and ethical considerations were far away from today's standards. Reflecting on him and how his story has been told across the years reminds us of the importance of treating everybody we encounter with dignity and respect and of course of the importance of informed consent. That is the ability to say no and to understand how you will be used and what will be said about you and in what way. Of course, it also would give you an indication of what the negative consequences for taking part might be. Then again, of course,
在19世纪，当然可以说，记录和伦理考量远未达到今天的标准。反思他以及他的故事多年来是如何被讲述的，提醒我们对待每一个我们遇到的人都要有尊严和尊重，当然还有知情同意的重要性。也就是拒绝的能力，以及理解你将如何被使用、关于你将说些什么以及以何种方式被讲述。当然，这也应该让你了解参与其中可能带来的负面后果。话又说回来，当然，
there are the additional ethical considerations, whether somebody with a traumatic brain injury, especially immediately after their accident, whether they really have what we call capacity to consent. Do they really understand? Can they hold that in mind long enough to be able to make those decisions? Identity and biology. Finally, Phineas Gage's case sparks philosophical questions. How much of who we are is shaped by our biology? And what happens when that biology changes. Conclusion. So what can we learn from Phineas Gage? His story is testament to the resilience of the human brain and the profound impact of biology on behavior. It's a story that reminds us both of the fragility and of course the adaptability of the human brain and mind. I want to leave you with this question. How do you think brain injuries shape identity? Do you think we are defined by our biology or is there something
还有额外的伦理考量，即患有创伤性脑损伤的人，特别是在事故发生后立即，是否真的具备我们所说的同意能力。他们真的理解吗？他们能保持足够长时间的记忆来做出这些决定吗？身份与生物学。最后，菲尼亚斯·盖奇的案例引发了哲学问题。我们有多少部分是由我们的生物学塑造的？当这种生物学发生变化时会发生什么？结论。那么我们能从菲尼亚斯·盖奇身上学到什么？他的故事证明了人类大脑的韧性以及生物学对行为的深远影响。这是一个提醒我们人类大脑和心灵既脆弱又具有适应性的故事。我想留给你这个问题。你认为脑损伤是如何塑造身份的？你认为我们是由我们的生物学定义的，还是有某种
more to who we are and what makes us, us? Let me know your thoughts in the comments. Do come and connect with me on socials and discuss it there. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If you found this video interesting don't forget to like, subscribe and share it with others who might also like to explore these incredible insights into psychology and neuroscience. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership which you can join from just £ pounds a month and there's also the clinical psychologist collective book the grief collective book the aspiring psychologist collective book an autistic anthology and talking heads too if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide.
超越生物学的东西构成了我们，构成了“我们”本身？请在评论中告诉我你的想法。欢迎在社交媒体上与我联系并讨论。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。如果你觉得这个视频很有趣，别忘了点赞、订阅并分享给其他可能也想探索这些关于心理学和神经科学的惊人见解的人。如果你准备好迈出下一步，请务必查看“准心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），每月仅需1英镑即可加入。此外还有《临床心理学家合集》、《悲伤合集》、《准心理学家合集》、《自闭症选集》和《Talking Heads 2》。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这些成为你的指南。
With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything
有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是由Marianne Trent博士主持的《准心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》，发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。各种各样的途径让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家并没有完美的道路。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切
will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。